el hartazgo es compartido por los
habitantes de beijing la capital de
china ha endurecido de las restricciones
sanitarias para controlar el aumento de
los casos de colitis 9
las restricciones en beijing son muy
severas ni siquiera puedo ir a comer a
ningún lado y amor el cáncer
no me infecte pero todavía me siento
enjaulado como si estuviera enferma
siento que estas restricciones son
excesivas agitan a la gente no pueden
soportarlo
y restaurantes cerrados parques
temáticos y atracciones limitando sus
aforos a un 50% hacen parte de la nueva
cotidianidad de la ciudad
las medidas se enmarcan en la política
de 'cero cobit que defiende el gobierno
exigen ping pero una buena parte de los
cerca de 22 millones de habitantes de la
capital temen por los efectos económicos
de las nuevas resoluciones
definitivamente vendemos menos que antes
los clientes no pueden entrar al
restaurante y los que piden comida
también son menos estamos afectados por
esta situación y nuestros ingresos
también son menores
y la ciudad ha implementado una nueva
ronda de pruebas masivas especialmente
concentradas en el distrito de chaoyang
donde se han reportado gran parte de los
contagios mientras en beijing las
autoridades temen un brote como el de
shanghai que lleva una larga y estricta
cuarentena en dicha ciudad los casos
comienzan a disminuir dando la esperanza
de una posible apertura